all I can't even doing on all my [ __ ]
fresh big ass is here now
and say somebody
oh my God
yo can we stop you guys you guys are
rich famous people or quasi famous
people and you only talk crazy to women
listen
like if that's not Behavior I don't know
what it is pop smoke what are you
looking for
basically they're planning on the one
girl in the top right area because she
got a deep voice y'all been good though
oh yeah women yeah yeah yeah we're good
yeah we're really good
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you think your voice sound a little
bit masculine or not I'm just a strong
woman and that what it is yeah like yeah
I was speaking another language
it's completely different I'm only
bringing that up because I think on this
podcast expect you know women to be a
little bit you know more feminine being
their feminine energy type [ __ ] you
wanna be your feminine energy
you feel like you know I mean you be
like in your feminine energy like you
know you know feminine energy yes
nurturing caring yeah of course for the
peoples that I love and care I just want
to know why your voice is that [ __ ]
deep
no it's not
pop smoke
okay
with deep voice is not here no no I
don't have no problem with it I never
give a [ __ ] about nobody to talk
anything about my voice so the way I
will call anything like I I literally
don't care okay is it your voice or you
uh or are you are your actions also kind
of matching voice in terms of
masculinity ah because I'm Alpha yeah oh
you are alpha
women okay I'm dominant that's what it
is
no wait we not wait no you don't have to
because I'm not asking you to fight I
don't like disrespect and I'm come
correct no no I'm not I'm not trying
I'm not trying to disrespect you
I'm telling I'm not trying to disrespect
you but you sound like a [ __ ] if I
heard pop smoke talking from Heaven
while I'm stroking I'm sorry
what do you have to lose some weight
until you can see your dick
but she's not being disrespected no no
she's matching the energy she's just
talking yeah
don't be mad when you were calling her a
[ __ ] right and you would say she sound
like a man like pop smoking you all this
up you are being disrespectful she's not
being disrespectful either right so we
good academics you fat you know this
it's cool
so you're saying that if I lose some
weight and I become your broke ass [ __ ]
ass boyfriend all right oh [ __ ] and I
started [ __ ] with a masculine [ __ ]
like you with fake titties right with a
[ __ ] tattoo on your face yeah [ __ ]
you're mad you're just naming me you are
so mad
oh wow bro you guys were clowning her
for a good 10 20 minutes she just said
by the way you're fat
you know she said she had a husband you
keep calling her the boyfriend like
you're doing all this because you're mad
you got mad and it's fine you guys been
on her and she's just been going back at
you guys for the same energy now you
really mad how are you gonna be sounding
how I'm gonna be sounding yeah what the
[ __ ] all right it's different like you
know I'm saying everybody [ __ ] like
fat [ __ ] like you so what's the
problem
yeah there's people that like what I am
and it's okay and [ __ ] like you
know
at this point you know what's making her
[ __ ] funny too is the fact that she
don't care okay she's like hey man who
cares who cares but some guys like what
I got some [ __ ] like fat [ __ ] like
you or it's it's different like you know
I'm saying everybody just like fat
[ __ ] like you so what's the problem
this is a rich [ __ ] like me right I bet
your boyfriend it was the matter I bet
your boyfriend never recite me
he said your boyfriend had rich like
ain't a rich [ __ ] like me and she's
like well yeah but he you you can't [ __ ]
me like he can [ __ ] me either so we good
she's she's this involved that's how we
call them she don't care and this guy's
trying to call it he's not as good as me
he didn't is the biggest the the thing
is that he's trying to win one
with all this [ __ ] that he threw
with all this [ __ ] that he threw he's
trying to get the one that's gonna get
her and it doesn't get her and and and
and and it's funny
it's funny because at the beginning of
the show
she said she was Alpha
and everybody clowned her because of
that and I was just like I don't care
people like Mia and he's the one doing
all this rah-rah [ __ ] he's trying to
qualify himself to her
so you're so you're submitting to her
that's the whole submission my dude I
don't know I don't even know if you
noticed this yeah in the beginning she
called herself Alpha everybody was
laughing that's fun and now you trying
to get one you're trying to get one that
she's so she knows like and she's like
I'm above this [ __ ] whatever come on you
trying to reach to my level fine and
then you just you're doing all this
rah-rah [ __ ] so we better than you
[ __ ] right it's as much as much as you
as much as you trying to clown her and
everything she won she won because
you're trying to prove yourself to her
so so you're saying I'm better than your
boyfriend I'm richer she's like she
don't care because she's good right it's
like if I got a girl some girl said I'm
better look at them I don't care I'm
good with my girlfriend who cares you
look stupid trying to tell me that
you're better than me I don't care so
I'm watching this and it's funny to me
because y'all was kind of just like
reset for being Alpha turns out
she is she is way more than y'all but I
bet you live in a [ __ ] Section 8
Housing and I live in a [ __ ] mansion
with me
she said you still unhappy because if
you wasn't that happy you wouldn't be
this aggressive and rude with with and
I'm not
you're you're you're you're you're
validating someone that nobody [ __ ]
knows you try to validate yourself to a
nobody
and I'm not cloning this girl saying
that she's nobody but nobody knows her
and it's fine she's popular oh she is
yeah okay then I'm just the one that
doesn't know you which is fine yeah
which is fine but you chill you still
trying to match that like you just and
when she said you're the one that's
unhappy
maybe you can claim that you're happy
but someone that would be happy and
content with whatever the [ __ ] they have
wouldn't have to prove yeah but yeah but
this [ __ ] is over it's done with she
doesn't give a [ __ ] it's a rap wrap it
up you know what I mean but if you don't
so you gotta run around say I got money
I got subscribers I got a Bugatti and if
you gotta feel the need to go back
that's whack that's what I'm saying but
it's worse when well I got more money
than you I got you because this is just
I'm just showing out loud money now
you're trying to put other [ __ ]
down just to put approval points you
unhappy yeah here's the thing with me
it's like if someone comes to me it's
like yo I got more money maybe you do
maybe I don't care oh I'm good [ __ ] I'm
a billionaire congratulations oh okay
why do you feel the need to come tell me
you have so much more when I don't care
that tells me that you're a loser on the
inside even though you might be winning
in these live how you look at yourself
the way that you internally to yourself
it's like I am a bit of a loser [ __ ]
maybe she is awful [ __ ] so all this
rah-rah all this need to get drunk and
do all this wild stuff is evidence that
you're a loser fresh my man's 28 going
on 80 and I don't want that to be you
guys and that's why today's sponsor t.h
Henley is coming in to save the day I
get compliments on my skin all the time
people will be asking what's your
skincare routine how do you get your
skin and for a lot of fellas talking
about skin care is a little bit awkward
because either we're too ashamed to do
it or it seems a little bit too feminine
but the truth is having rough skin or
having all these little dents everywhere
isn't some that you necessarily want
especially if it's things that you can
easily avoid through very very good
products I recommend going through that
process and that's where TJ Hanley comes
in they got a great system in place
where you can use their products to
achieve your skin care goals I
personally recommend that you start with
the level one system which comes with
all the basics a daily face wash which
gets rid of all the dirt and Grime on
your face then got it two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of all the
dead skin cells and an AM moisturizer
with SPF 20 because we all need to make
sure that our skin is protected from the
Sun and the cool thing about Tia Shanley
is all their boxes come with
instructions in addition to amazing skin
members of th Henley get tons of
benefits like at least 20 off retail
price the ability to pause or cancel at
any time as well as free us shipping and
because thinly sponsoring today's video
if you go to the link in the description
below not only will you get all the
benefits that I just listed but you'll
also get a free gift with your purchase
don't wait rub out that face so you can
actually start looking fresh
you're all happy baby like you got you
got to stop like be acting like weird
not
es it's not my problem if you want Happy
like I'm very ready
I'm asking you a question you sound like
hold on relax relax
you could afford to get in this building
okay oh my God
yo can we stop he couldn't afford to get
in this building what a loser bro you
couldn't afford to get in this club
that's how much money we got first I've
been in that building it's not that
impressive okay it's fine but just sit
there like who cares
like the people who brag about money
like this in the argument are the
biggest losers yeah well I make more
bands than you okay
okay uh
I got a bigger dick than you
and you didn't notice look at the other
guys of this panel these dudes burning
his head in his hand right this guy
looks like he's completely disintered
even sneakers doing the cringe face
disrespectful boy
let somebody say something
I'm happy [ __ ] my boy
that sounds very familiar We Are Better
Than You [ __ ] period
you are you doing some some kissing and
telling your [ __ ] kiss and tell you
she says that's disrespectful it's like
well I know who you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] am I even watching are you
doing some gossipy [ __ ] where you're
talking about who slept with who because
she said what you said on air is
disrespectful
what are we watching
bro I I clocked out all that cap you've
been doing on all my [ __ ] fresh big
accused here now
what the [ __ ] is going top hey bro yo
what is up with these like red pill
Alpha dudes who seem to have so much
energy when they're dealing with these
ladies
bro you know yeah I wish you would have
said that to a dude talk the same way to
a big dude I wish you would then I might
take you seriously because I remember
when these guys had Kodak Black on and
he was being all kinds of disrespectful
none of these dudes checked a single one
of them they didn't check Kodak they
didn't check none of these guys Why you
wanna you wanna know what that's what I
noticed and this is what makes me lose
respect for a lot of these guys is they
only have this energy for people that
are weaker than them they will never see
any of this stuff to dudes that are
bigger stronger to them they'll never
say dudes stuff that got way more clout
to them and can actually influence them
negative Fleek right even if they
vehemently disagree on the principle
they start sucking dick and keeping
quiet because but moment it's a woman
where they have nothing to lose and
everything to gain by being
disrespectful they don't just be this
they go the extra mile but you know
maybe it's just where I came from you're
generally judged by how you behave when
you have power
that's it you want to test a man's
character give him power put in front of
the powerless and see how they act this
woman was just here she had a deep voice
and [ __ ] were on her case they
were asking all kinds of private
questions and she was still and then
when they were insulting insulted and
then she said while we're back they
tripled quadruple down him not they they
just didn't you know what this is
go ahead this is Alonzo Harris
you know who Alonso Harrison is Denzel
Washington's character in Training Day
he's all calm cool calm and collected
when's the one time that he was yelling
when's the one time that he was yelling
at the end of the movie when he lost
everything when when now he's trying to
keep going when they start yelling
that's when they all losing power and
try trying to regain that power that's
what it is why are you screaming like
that
why
she's not eating she's not even
screaming and one girl said it's
disrespectful not even yelling why are
you yelling big act big action shut the
[ __ ] up everybody's seen you [ __ ] out
in front of a bunch of rappers and
people who checked you you know I
remember when Migos came on the set when
you were Joe Budden and you were there
like a child looking for his papa at the
[ __ ] State Fair because you got
separated like don't act big on these
platforms because you talking to a
random nobody that's loser [ __ ]
it is but maybe y'all feel different I
just think it's funny that it's always
the same dudes who are doing a lot of
this preaching and a lot of this stuff
about like you know this is the
prescriptions I have for the world this
is how guys gotta behave and all this
stuff and you realize they face a bit of
adversity you give them a bit of power
and these turn they do they turn into
tyrants or losers right who can't even
hold frame you got a woman who's way
more Alpha than any of these dudes
combined who's chilling you got more
money cool you had a bigger cool
I'm happy with my children and my
husband so what
Becky's here now big Act is in the bill
who are you talking to well if you want
to be hard go do it in the right places
but you won't because you were coward
you know oh yeah yeah
and say somebody say something
that's why you're on camera
camera
thought so we'll talk about okay you
should come back I don't think so
where's my phone all right pressure
exactly okay so uh oh
[Music]
yeah
you saw you on the show learn from Big
actor yeah I could see your pubes
through your panties right now I'm not
gonna lie
I don't know how you fit on a plane with
that BBL and you're you open it to the
mic but I I legitimate you know they're
like not even trying to arrest you like
I could see your whole Bush through your
pants
and the guy beside him is just like bruh
what are we doing right now what are you
doing right now because I haven't signed
up for this [ __ ]
hey shout out to him
whoever's to do in America he's the only
one who's like yo this is weird but
we're gonna end this show
I'm just saying like it's very visible
[Music]
we don't take no disrespect lately here
period
if you're willing to give disrespect you
have to be willing to take it
you that's and that's the only thing
it's not because you say no disrespect
that it's not disrespectful okay you've
been doing none but that and the minute
one person says one thing you take it
like that bro you can't be like ah we
don't take no disrespect then don't
disrespect if you don't want to start
nothing there won't be nothing and you
started and then she matched your energy
just a bit talking all that [ __ ]
y'all come out of my this big guy kill
the building [ __ ]
[Music]
I never heard about you I'm sorry [ __ ]
we never heard about you yeah you a
masculine looking [ __ ] with a face type
[ __ ] and some fake titties my [ __ ] we
think you're a [ __ ] hell to keep a
reality
[ __ ] what's going on right now what this
[ __ ] doing right now yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
the dude went oh and he went back to the
girl because he wasn't going to talk to
the man that way he just kept going at
her the whole time and try to ignore him
because he's not gonna have that same
energy for him he's a [ __ ]
their [ __ ] here's the thing I don't
talk crazy because one I'm not that
person and two you catch me in person
I'm generally respectful and cool that's
how I am I don't act different I don't
act all brand new I don't see fans
they'd be like [ __ ] you know what it is
I don't see that's corny
people who act differently based on what
circles they're at or how they're like
in this drastic change
you look corny to me
you look corny to me I I look Hey listen
people keep whatever friends they want I
think it's bad for the show because that
whole thing looks like a hot mess but
hey ah it's just
there's people that that like that so
that that that thing that that thing the
no what I mean by that is that people
like that that they show you say it's
bad for the show I think the people that
are watching that are watching that for
that this is Jerry Springer's this is
the new era of of Mori this is what it
is the audience doesn't like it science
is all against this episode really yeah
so that's why really I didn't know you
know what then I'm gonna give it to you
I'm really sorry I really thought that
because I really thought that
[ __ ] was looking at that they
were looking at that so for that kind of
stuff women being like Frank Castle and
stuff like that and people are going no
they definitely look for some of that
for sure yeah yeah so that that that's
why like I was under the impression that
people looked like look at that show for
that which is fine everybody got their
entertainment I mean you know I mean and
that and that's fine that's good you
know
um so that's why that's why I said that
comments I'm like yeah [ __ ]
like that maybe they don't look that
that was weird I would never wanted to
be in that spot I don't envy nobody that
was on that spot
because that that was hella weird that
was super weird even the people that
were there were like yo this ain't it
this ain't it but
this is what I think I think people in
the online World keep weird friends
I think people keep weird friends
that's why I look a lot of these
people's sus
I'm like is that how you act okay I
gotta keep my distance all right because
I I one I don't associate with that kind
of stuff and you you look [ __ ] goofy
in the real world most folks will get
slapped up for this Behavior
what you doing like you think I'll be in
my neighborhood talking to somebody's
wife that way
what do you
I don't know where y'all from but that's
a crazy way to talk to people and it's
expecting to be okay so I don't get to
this position where I'm at now and all
of a sudden act brand new
I don't even have any I I don't
understand this stuff this is the kind
of like so if you guys if this is or if
these are the people you take your cues
from okay
but I look at them like they're sus
that's me personally I don't know what
it is but ever since I joined this
online world I've noticed a lot of
people who say a lot of goofy stuff that
I feel like they would never say to
anybody in person no they wouldn't
they want they wouldn't they went they
wouldn't stand on any of their stuff but
they get in front of these cameras and
all of a sudden the way that they talk
is completely different we had the proof
of that you know we meet
sometimes you meet some friends that
were talking crazy and you were going
back and forth when we finally meet them
this city is real small and then they
all nice and then no but what I meant
was no no you you said what you said say
now I'm here say it again and it's not I
was not looking for you it's sort of
happened that would oh you're that dude
that was [ __ ] talking crazy what's up
were you about to I'm right here what
were you about to do
no but what I meant was that's not what
you meant stop doing that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] whack
but people people are like that yeah
Facebook gangsters are social media
gangsters they they they a lot of people
do talk crazy and you you guys are only
talking crazy to women
you guys you guys are rich famous people
or quasi famous people and you only talk
crazy to women listen
like if that's not [ __ ] Behavior I
don't know what it is
you made fun of her for five ten minutes
because she got a deep voice she said
one thing you went off but you may
before she even did that you guys were
clowning her because she got a deep
voice who cares
imagine a group of girls just sitting
there laughing at a dude in the circle
because he's five foot tall I'd call
them [ __ ] losers too this is no
different and all these dudes are out
here trying to give young men advice on
how to live life go clean your rooms
Jordan Peterson says it you guys fixing
other dudes you need to clean your own
lives up you guys need some therapy you
need to figure out what's wrong with
your anger issues or your [ __ ]
insecurities where you guys are just
lashing out at people because they made
one comment about your weight or they
said oh uh you will seem a little
scrawny yo who cares if you can't
control your anger and your behavior
because someone made one comment you
need help after you did all that after
you talk as much [ __ ] about other people
after you guys are clowning all these
people they make one comment you guys
sitting there
get some help
get some help y'all need that [ __ ]
because when she said you guys seem
unhappy what happy person goes around
screaming at people aggressively for
that trying to prove themselves to
strangers you touch a cord
to strangers touch the cord what the
[ __ ] I care about some random [ __ ]
think about me bing bing bing bing bing
bing you touched that and she was right
these are the ones that the outfits
telling you to hold your frame never let
her get you off kilter you're fat I'm
better than you [ __ ] okay damn okay
that girl was right all along